a vigil honoring a father of nine killed  last week is going on right now Sasha  Loftus is there joining us now live with  more  Denise and Brian this vigil is just  getting ready to start here at six  o'clock you can see dozens already  Gathering to honor Janae Dominguez who  just a few days after he was killed now  police say Dominguez was shot and killed  Tuesday while working at all in towing a  company that he co-owned an arrest  report says the suspect in the case  27-year-old Jatan herder came to pick up  his Tesla that was towed with some  issues with paperwork led to an argument  officers say herder shot Dominguez and  ran off herder later turned himself in  now we plan on speaking with dominguez's  family and those who knew and loved him  through this vigil tonight we will of  course be here all evening and keep you  updated both on air and online as this  event continues and have more for you  tonight on 8 news now at 11 o'clock  reporting live Sasha Loftus 8 News Now